park how we doing brother first of all
i'm asian
yes and i'm getting attacked frequently
because of my race
oh my gosh hey hold on man hold on hold
on
okay dude i'm sorry
ah yeah man i'm heartbroken for you tell
me about what's going on
so um last week i was at the parking lot
at the front of the grocery store
and there was a man who called me like
chinese virus
and he said go back to comedy to china
you don't deserve to be here
so he even kicked my shopping cart
i'm not exaggerating he kicked my
shopping cart and
i had to pick up all the stuffs from the
ground
so do you buy stuff i'm healthy
no no one helped me wow
no one helped me so i was so scared yeah
i felt so lonely
yeah and then so
i'm so scared of going out and buying
groceries going to class
i feel like i might get killed because
of my race
you know yeah dude i'm so sparked man
hey
i'm so so sorry how old are you man uh
23
23 what are you studying yeah uh i'm
studying economics in college
yeah um what school what school are you
at
my school yeah um
uh you know you don't tell me that you
don't tell me that that's cool um okay
so tell me about tell me about who you
are tell me about your story
okay so first of all i'm from south
korea
yeah and i moved to the united states
after i finished my elementary school
from south korea because of my parents
job
yeah so i first moved to boston and i
attended the middle school there
and after that after finishing middle
school
i had to decide whether i go back to
south korea for high school
or stay in the united states and then
i decided to stay in the united states
and then i attended high school and at
the time i
stayed at the homestay
and after that i finished my high school
and then
i got accepted to the college in indiana
and i and i moved to indiana and
right now i'm staying in apartments
going to school studying economics and
also
i'm doing remote internships at one of
the
software like it software company in
silicon valley
so awesome hey good for you dude listen
i hate this it's disgusting
and it's evil and
that crap should not be going on man
absolutely listen to me um
it shouldn't be going on and i'm sorry
that you can't go outside and you feel
scared to go to the grocery store
because somebody attacked you already
it's nonsense and it's ridiculous and
um i'm heartbroken for you i'm
heartbroken for the
idiots who think that's a good idea and
that makes them feel better i'm
heartbroken for you i'm heartbroken for
the
pastor buys who didn't stop and
intervene
and even those who were terrified who
didn't stop and help you pick up your
stuff i'm heartbroken by the whole mess
dude
you deserve better than this from from
the citizens of indianapolis and you
deserve better than this from the cities
citizens of your community and park i'm
sorry
thank you for yeah i know that doesn't
make you any safer at the grocery store
brother but i'm sorry
i should not tell you tell me about your
community there do you have a group of
people that you love and interact with
are you stuck all by yourself
people isolating you tell me what's
what's going on in your community there
so you know since last year
i have been staying by myself because
majority of my friends are
international students like mostly from
china
taiwan sure and some people from like
vietnam
and since kobe 19 hit the united states
very hard
majority of them went back to their
country
and i also tried to get a flight ticket
but it was so expensive and also
you know in south korea if i entered
there i had to do self
quarantine for two weeks right and i
have to pay for it
and also due to time zone difference
like
it is so difficult for me to take class
during the midnight
like two or three a.m in the morning in
south korea so it's nonsense for me so
i just decided to stay in the united
states and
since covet i have not
meeting my friend face to face only like
chatting
like facebook chat and that's it oh man
so listen you you you may have heard me
on the show before
understanding the physiology of that you
realize that your body is
slowly folding in on itself from
loneliness right
right and you're in a tough tough
situation because
you have to be in proximity to other
people you have to
you got to you've got to have a
community people that you can interact
with
talk to communicate with that will help
that your brain feel
safe and at the same time you're in a
situation now where you can't even go to
the grocery store man
i hate that um tell me about your
school when i was the student affairs
guy at multiple universities
we worked with students in your
situation to make sure they were safe to
provide them with some sort of community
to make sure they could
get to and from places if they needed to
there should be some support networks
built into the university are attending
is that available to you or no
that's available so actually like before
i send you the letter
i already talked to my academic advisor
and there is the organizations that
support international students
and i already talked to them but yeah i
feel like
um i have to share this story to
everybody you're exactly right ignorance
is the problem for the racism ignorance
is the major cause
yeah so you you're going out to a whole
bunch of people
right to millions of people if if
um and and you have done a brave thing
by calling into the show
and you've done a brave thing by putting
a name
in a situation to this i want everybody
listening here
a guy just went to get groceries
and somebody kicked over the cart called
him a bunch of derogatory names
that's something he has he's trying to
go to college
he's trying to help out you and your
communities
this type of stuff is disgusting man
so if you could say anything to the
millions of people
listening to this what would it be
i'm also belonging to your community
yeah
yes i'm asian but i'm not type of virus
i don't carry virus i already took kovit
testing for two
times and they're all negative i have
been very musk
i have been washing my hands i have been
following the rules
but why do i have to get blamed because
i'm asian
because i'm international student
because my accent is not american
that's ridiculous amen yeah
you're right so
here's what i want every listener to
hear when you're walking
at the grocery store looking at the
prices of the fruit
looking at is there any discounts on
cereal
and you see somebody that doesn't look
like you i want you to understand
they're having a totally different
experience in that aisle than you are
if they happen to be asian-american they
happen to be asian they happen to be
visiting your community putting money
into your community and getting educated
at the schools that you're attending to
like our friend park here i want you
know there's a chance that they are
walking down that aisle terrified that
you may reach out and hurt them
that you may reach out and kick their
cart over and no one's going to sit
there and
bend down and help you pick up your
stuff
and so i'm calling on every listener of
this podcast
every listener this podcast with kids
every listeners podcast who's married or
dating somebody who's got parents
open your mouths and open your eyes
what's happening is ridiculous it's
stupid
it's obnoxious and it's embarrassing for
our whole country
it's embarrassing we got to be better
than this park
i want to tell you on behalf of
everybody i'm glad you're here
thank you and i hope that the
ignorant ridiculous heartbreaking
actions of a few morons
will not um poison you to those of us
who love you and we're glad you're here
and i'm calling on folks of indianapolis
to step up i'm calling folks of every
city every place in the country to step
up and start serving the least of these
in our communities
especially those folks who don't look
like us because everybody's
fighting a battle inside their heart
mind every day and we just look like
we're pushing
grocery carts and we're not life's hard
the person walking in front of you in
the grocery store walking a little bit
too slow
you don't know what their marriage is
like you don't know if they got a kid in
the hospital
the young asian american guy the young
asian guy just going to get groceries
you don't know how terrified and how
tightly he's gripping that cart because
he's scared to death
park thank you so so much for your call
thanks for being brave and hey
um if somebody reaches out with a hand
of support let me know
if any more further nonsense calls let
me know please don't hesitate to call
the police
because they're there to serve you too
please don't hesitate to call your
campus
support networks because they're there
to support you too
please call on your academic advisors
please gather allies if possible let
your classmates know what you're
experiencing
let those kids in your internship class
know what you're experiencing
and my hope is when they hear your story
that you're no longer a headline you're
no longer an issue you're no longer
something happening in somebody else's
town
hey hold on that's our buddy park
no way dude we're all going to the store
now
park you're coming with us and that's
how we combat this nonsense
park you're coming with us
all of us no more no more
man no more
oh man james um
i'm gonna wrap up the show here and i
don't
i think we're good yeah i think we're
good
i'm out no song for today guys
men and women when your neighborhood
needs you
pull out your headphones and go help
your neighbor turn this podcast off help
your neighbor
this has been the dr john delaney show